i
[Música]
cinco personas perdieron la vida tras un
bombardeo ruso sobre una torre de
televisión en kiev el ataque se produjo
luego de que moscú pidiera a los civiles
que se encuentren en la capital
ucraniana que evacúen las zonas cercanas
a instalaciones de inteligencia o
propaganda todo esto el tiempo que las
partes anunciaron que la segunda ronda
de conversaciones se realizará este 2 de
marzo
ante el parlamento europeo y en un
sentido discurso el presidente vuelo de
1000 selenski pidió a europa que muestre
estar por el pueblo de ucrania a su vez
cargó contra vladimir putin por no
reconocer la magnitud del ataque que
lanzó en el que denunció están muriendo
menores
presidente estadounidense joe biden dará
su primer discurso sobre el estado de la
unión esta noche el mandatario llega
ante el congreso en medio de la crisis
por la invasión rusa a ucrania la
pandemia de coke 19 la creciente
inflación en el país analizamos en esta
emisión
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos esta emisión en
la capital ucraniana donde cinco
personas perdieron la vida tras un
ataque ruso contra una torre de
televisión de kiev el bombardeo se
produjo luego de que el ministerio de
defensa ruso anunciara que iba a atacar
centros de información y propaganda
ucranianos y pidiera a todos los civiles
que abandonaran las zonas cercanas
entretanto el avance de las tropas rusas
no se detiene la ofensiva continúa por
el sur el este y el norte del país
enfocando sus ataques en las ciudades de
mariupol gerson y hardcore con lo que el
kremlin busca controlar la mitad
oriental ucraniana así como la costa de
ese país en el mar negro todo esto
mientras que un extenso convoy avanza
hacia kiev asimismo la inteligencia
ucraniana indicó que rusia está
preparando una provocación deliberada
para justificar la entrada de tropas
bielorrusas al conflicto
previamente conversamos con irene sabio
enviada especial de france 24 que se
encuentra en la localidad de obús al sur
de quien dinos continúa el avance de las
tropas rusas
pues sí eso es correcto esa información
que tenemos nosotros también y hay que
decir que la ciudad se está preparando
en una forma increíble hay sacos de
arena
blindados civiles armados que han armado
múltiples puestos de control más de lo
que habíamos visto en los últimos días y
que se está realmente preparando ha
resistido a estas ataques aunque bueno
permanece la duda de cómo se llevarán a
cabo ese ataque porque sí
concentra son ataques aéreos de forma se
concentran sobre la rada el parlamento
ucraniano por ejemplo en la
ayuntamiento en la casa de gobierno se
trata de edificios que se encuentran en
el centro en el corazón de la ciudad y
por tanto
se espera que allí realmente sea
peligroso estar cerca
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski mantuvo una conversación de
alrededor de media hora con su homólogo
estadounidense joe biden discutieron
sobre las sanciones y la asistencia en
defensa que washington le pruebe a kiev
le provee a kiev más temprano desde
bruselas con una ovación unánime líderes
del parlamento europeo aplaudieron el
discurso de excelencia en el que aseguró
que su país está pagando un precio muy
alto por defender los ideales europeos
esto un día después de pedir formalmente
su ingreso al bloque marina sardiña
tiene los detalles
un hemiciclo lleno de banderas
ucranianas se puso en pie para aplaudir
al presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski menos de 24 horas después de su
pedido formal para ingresar a la unión
europea
el líder participó de la sesión del
parlamento europeo con un mensaje claro
un reino
muy del samur
sin ustedes ucrania estará sola hemos
demostrado nuestra fuerza hemos
demostrado al menos que somos como
ustedes
y aquí
así que demuestran ustedes que están con
nosotros demuestran que no nos abandonan
y que son realmente europeos así la vida
vencerá a la muerte y la luz vencerá a
las tinieblas gloria a ucrania el
respaldo a su petición en la eurocámara
lo tiene asegurado la presidenta de la
comisión europea anunció que el bloque
destinará más de 500 millones de euros
para paliar las consecuencias
humanitarias de la guerra entonces
tenido su crimen ser el destino de
ucrania está en juego pero nuestro
propio destino también está en la
balanza ander escuchen más sí que en
chivas y si putin busca dividir a la
unión europea debilitar a la otan y
romper la comunidad internacional ha
conseguido exactamente lo contrario cif
exacto de opus dei por su parte al
presidente del consejo europeo calificó
la invasión rusa de terrorismo
geopolítico
esto es terrorismo geopolítico puro y
duro
en un emotivo discurso el alto
representante de la unión europea en
asuntos exteriores pidió cancelar la
dependencia comunitaria de los
hidrocarburos rusos we will not
uy no vamos a abandonar la defensa de
nuestros derechos humanos y libertad
porque seamos más o menos dependientes
de rusia y tenemos que empezar a
trabajar rápido en el momento en el que
la comisión ha decidido empezar a
trabajar para cancelar su dependencia
esta comisión hast grupos i know that
you can see this de atenderse pese al
apoyo al mandatario ucraniano aún queda
un largo y burocrático camino a recorrer
para que la solicitud de adhesión de
ucrania a la unión europea se efectúe
desde el otro lado del atlántico el
secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken habló vía remota antes del
consejo de derechos humanos de la onu
indicó que rusia debería ser expulsada
de ese consejo y resaltó que las
violaciones rusas aumentan con el pasar
de las horas afectando escuelas y
hospitales asimismo añadió que el
kremlin también ha incrementado la
represión dentro del territorio ruso
los informes sobre los abusos de los
derechos humanos y las violaciones del
derecho internacional humanitario por
parte de rusia aumentan cada hora los
ataques rusos afectan a escuelas
hospitales y edificios residenciales
están destruyendo infraestructuras
críticas que abastecen a millones de
personas en todo gran ya de agua potable
y gas para evitar que se mueran de frío
han ido a chrysler el ministerio del
interior polaco informó que unas 350 mil
personas han huido a polonia desde
ucrania 100.000 de ellas en las últimas
24 horas con esto se eleva el número
total de refugiados a más de 660.000 sin
embargo la acnur denunció que se están
presentando casos de discriminación
cada vez que un autobús llega al paso
fronterizo de médica límite entre
ucrania y polonia es un revuelo las
temperaturas marcan niveles bajo cero y
la gente está desesperada
muchos de ellos son extranjeros que
vivían en ucrania dicen que han sido
tratados de forma diferente a los
ucranianos en su camino hacia polonia
dejaron entrar a los ucranianos mientras
que los extranjeros fueron segregados la
mayoría eran indios africanos algunos
ingleses que estaban allí y contenidos
escoceses
somos gestos nos hicieron esperar en el
frío durante horas
a los ucranianos se les permite utilizar
los autobuses pero nosotros tuvimos que
ir a pie estábamos sorprendidos
en respuesta a los informes sobre los
residentes no ucranianos que son
retenidos en las fronteras la unión
africana dijo que esto es
escandalosamente racista y en violación
del derecho internacional por su parte
el embajador polaco ante la onu negó
tales afirmaciones
los nacionales de todos los países que
han sufrido la agresión rusa o cuya vida
está en peligro pueden buscar refugio en
mi país acogimos a personas de 125
nacionalidades hasta esta crisis polonia
había impuesto normas estrictas en
materia de asilo ahora es el país vecino
de ucrania que más refugiados acoge los
funcionarios de la unión europea dicen
que la guerra podría desplazar hasta
siete millones de personas
cambiamos de tema y vamos hasta eeuu
porque esta noche el presidente joe
biden pronunciará ante el congreso su
primer discurso del estado de la unión
las declaraciones del mandatario
llegarán en medio de este tenso panorama
internacional pero también en medio de
la inflación que vive eeuu conectamos
con ana maría salazar analista política
especialista en temas de seguridad y ex
subsecretaria adjunta en el pentágono
bienvenida a france 24 hay una crítica
bastante fuerte dentro de eeuu los
republicanos aseguran que durante la
presidencia a barack obama rusia se
anexó crimea y que ahora estamos viendo
esta invasión mientras que durante la
administración de donald trump la
relación fue algo confusa pero había
cierto nivel de entendimiento
necesita una mano más fuerte para lidiar
con el kremlin
yo creo que de hecho una de las grandes
lecciones que aprendió el presidente yo
baiden habiendo sido el vicepresidente
de barack obama es que no se tomaron los
pasos contundentes en ese momento para
detener esa invasión lo que estamos
viendo en este momento es uno de los
temas seguramente que tendrá que
discutir y presentar ante el pueblo
estadounidense el presidente yo baiden
es la necesidad no solamente de crear
este consenso internacional con países
de la otan con países de países
latinoamericanos con los países de la
unión europea de crear un frente común
ante esta ante la agresión rusa pero en
ese mismo discurso también tiene que
justificar el dolor y pues los costos
que podría haber para la economía
estadounidense de estas decisiones que
se están haciendo particularmente como
lo menciona estoy muy bien en un momento
en donde la inflación está en un alto
histórico y en donde no se ve que se
pueda resolver este problema de
inflación particularmente en este
momento antes canciones que se están
llevando a cabo desde su perspectiva
eeuu está haciendo suficiente en medio
de esta crisis o debería jugar un papel
diferente
interesante tu pregunta porque lo que
seguiría probablemente y lo que algunos
críticos podrían estar pidiendo es que
tuviera una presencia militar eeuu en
este conflicto y yo creo que el el eso
está
muy lejos de ser una de las
consideraciones pero lo que sí está
sucediendo es que se está proporcionando
armas probablemente se está
proporcionando inteligencia
probablemente se está proporcionando
ciertas capacidades que tiene eeuu la
otan y países europeos para asegurar la
protección de civiles entonces en cierta
forma lo que lo que son las sanciones
económicas
probablemente va a ser el factor que
podría ayudar a detener la agresión
eventualmente o encontrar una una
solución el problema de sanciones
económicas como no sabes tú lo sabe todo
tu auditorio es que no son no son
inmediatas el impacto y entonces habría
que ver en qué momento
vladimir putin va a buscar una salida al
conflicto pero creo que todavía falta
falta días y posiblemente semanas a eso
bueno vemos esta atención internacional
y también hay tensión dentro del país ya
usted lo mencionaba debido a los efectos
económicos de la pandemia que podemos
esperar del pronunciamiento de byd en
esta noche
yo creo que entre otras es buscarle el
apoyo del pueblo estadounidense
justificación de este de este apoyo y la
necesidad de crear un consenso
internacional
y sobre todo entender por qué va a haber
este un impacto económico en los
bolsillos de los estadounidenses y por
otra parte yo creo que va a tratar de
crear consenso alrededor de los grandes
temas que ha puesto sobre la mesa una
reforma una reforma electoral y
conseguir apoyos y más más apoyo a la
población más necesitada eeuu y no me
sorprendería que va a tratar de usar
este discurso para tratar de crear una
más unidad dentro del partido demócrata
en un momento en donde se ha visto o se
ha percibido divisiones importantes
señora salazar a usted muchas gracias
por su análisis y por compartirlo con
nosotros en france24 estamos pendientes
de lo que ocurra esta noche con el
discurso del estado de la unión del
presidente yo bailé no cambiamos de tema
y vamos hasta argentina el presidente
alberto fernández inauguró el periodo
número 140 de sesiones ordinarias en el
congreso y anunció que aún hoy el
gobierno continúa negociando aspectos
del acuerdo que se logró hace un mes con
el fondo monetario internacional para
refinanciar la deuda del país desde
buenos aires nuestro corresponsal
natalio coso y nos informó más temprano
sobre los detalles de la negociación que
informó fernández si bueno qué tal no
mucho más de lo que se conocía hasta
ahora la realidad es que había cierta
expectativa de que este acuerdo se
podría haber cerrado antes se podría
haber inaugurado esta está legislativa
de 2022 con un acuerdo avanzado y que el
congreso tuviera que dar su visto bueno
al acuerdo el acuerdo contempla sobre
todo la refinanciación de los 44 mil
millones de dólares de deuda que tomó el
gobierno de mauricio macri y la
postergación del inicio de los pagos
hasta 2026 y por supuesto también unas
revisiones trimestrales de los acuerdos
que alcance a argentina con el fondo
monetario internacional que tienen que
ver con por ejemplo reducción del
déficit fiscal y un punto difícil de las
9 y acciones que tiene que ver con la
reducción de los subsidios a los
consumos de energía eléctrica y gas en
los hogares un tema muy delicado porque
además genera rispideces y discusiones
al interior de la colisión del gobierno
del presidente alberto fernández en
cisjordania se llevó a cabo el funeral
de dos jóvenes palestinos que
fallecieron por disparos del ejército
israelí miles de personas inundaron las
calles para acompañar el desfile fúnebre
de los dos palestinos de 18 y 22 años
que murieron en medio de una redada en
el norte de cisjordania según las
autoridades los hechos ocurrieron cuando
buscaban a un sospechoso de actividad
terrorista
[Música]
y finalizamos en reino unido porque tras
superar el coi 19 la reina isabel
segunda celebró dos audiencias virtuales
en un comunicado del palacio de
buckingham indicó que la monarca de 95
años ya se encuentra bien de salud y por
ello recibió virtualmente a los
embajadores de andorra y chad desde su
casa en el castillo de windsor
es todo por el momento en france 24 les
agradecemos su sintonía los invitamos a
continuar con nosotros que volvemos en
breve con más noticias
[Música]